let's talk some paradise drama Hannah
right now is the puppeteer we all
defended Hannah going for Dylan and
thinking things a bad guy but really
hannah has the power and Dylan and Blake
are just fighting for her attention
don't play that game you and tisha have
had some issues on the show which I
think it surprised some fans you guys
were together and Colton Underwood
season and we've heard her call you
manipulative a puppet master how did
that feel for you to watch back that's
stucked watching back I think she's
totally entitled to her opinion and I'm
I'm good with a little bit of healthy
confrontation but watching back I was
just like out you know it heard it stung
but I'm okay with moving forward and
past it she is and yeah I mean it wasn't
fun just because you know you I'm over
here like I'm trying to figure my stuff
out and and then she's saying yeah
Nicole go in all these dates and I'm
like you know it's just there's so many
different sides of it and I was just
what do you say what do you say to those
accusations that you were manipulating
that you were doing things with one guy
in front of another guy I think I would
say to ask any of the people in my
circle and my close group of friends
that know me and love me and none of
them would say that because I'm not like
that and I think I know deep down I know
that I approach everything with the
bus's of intentions and so it was really
really hard and heavy watching somebody
say that about me because I haven't been
in something like that before I feel
like she mean girl'd me can you clear
this up once and for all what happened
in Alabama with Blake yeah
I thought that was like a private thing
that he did and out of respect for him I
didn't want to though everything like
that
I thought this would be a better place
to figure things out so II the reason
why he came out there was to have a
conversation with me about the whole
Kaelin thing and I wasn't sure I was
like uh and that's why he was like I'm
coming down and I was like don't come
like whatever and you didn't want him to
come all the way down
he said he cancelled his fight he told
me that he canceled his flight because I
was like seems a little shady like
whatever I was like it's fine like you
know let's talk to paradise like
whatever and he said he cancelled it the
next day I was shopping and he said hey
what are you doing I was like shopping
and he was like okay I just landed in
Alabama so I did feel like I owed it to
him it was a gesture and it's it was
just one of those things or us like
let's have let's have a combo let's see
how it goes this is old it's so hard
like I'm not gonna give up a bucket on
the towel I was like the thought of it
was him hey man
why date him when you'd maybe heard some
about his past like something about the
stagecoach thing like why did you even
get into things in paradise with Blake I
think I just truly had a connection and
from my from what I was told there
wasn't any emotions attached to all of
that I was already trying to figure it
all out myself I was like I'm not really
sure if that's something I wouldn't be
involved with but from what I had heard
he was like yeah everybody like we're
all on the same page about telling like
you about it like I see a potential with
you like whatever so I definitely wanted
to let you know so I had a different
understanding and watching back I didn't
realize that there was so many emotions
attached to it or I would have been like
taking more steps back so that was
definitely what I hold on to I think for
that you know it's a weekend and I'm
just like trying to figure everything
out and giving every possible connection
a chance